okay first of all i want to thank
everybody for coming out
and thank all of the national guard
folks that are here with us today as
well as all the other speakers
really we're opening back up our texas
facility it was
very important so we want to thank our
private partners as well but
this really is the time that we've been
talking about for a very long time
we are now in blue season and so we have
to encourage
folks to get out get tested and to
change their behavior
nobody knows more than myself covet
fatigue we all feel it
we've been doing this for a very long
time but we're not
past the critical point yet to where we
can let our guard down
so what i would tell you is for all
those folks out there if you've been out
and about in the last
three to four weeks where it's been
beautiful weather like it is today and
you've seen friends and family that you
haven't really seen for
months please come out and get tested
this is a very easy and simple process
please continue to wash your hands on a
regular basis
and please limit your gatherings
so that you're only around people you're
social distancing you're wearing your
face covering
and washing your hands so that we can
get through this together as a community
and we can get on into the next year so
with that i'm going to invite chief
steinbach up
because it's important to explain to
folks how easy this process really is
but remember this is for the good of the
whole community community testing
is something that we're better at than
most places so
i encourage everybody to do their part
today so chief steinbeck
thank you madam chair
yes so we're opening back up the texas
site uh that's to
address increased commit demand here in
the community
um i want to thank umc the national
guard
uh the southern nevada health district
our our neighboring fire departments and
and
certainly my staff for the work to put
this back together
i do i do want to
work off of what the commissioner just
said is that this is an easy
process we're the fire department's
involved in this on the operational side
so it's our job to make this as
efficient as possible
so that we can get you back out onto
your day as quickly as possible
and really fulfill our goals which is to
identify
those that may have this illness and to
uh quickly help them to isolate and to
keep it from spreading
and then assist them from that point
moving forward
and so this just gives us the
opportunity to do that again we can
easily take
another 2 000 people a day through here
even more without having long wait times
and we don't anticipate anybody having
wait times over 15 minutes at least
unless there's a surge that's that's
unexpected
moving forward we've tried to make the
registration process as easy as possible
as well
and so you can access that through the
southern nevada health district website
um as well as uh at cove
if you were to text covet to the phone
number 844-990-0029
you'll get a code sent to you that'll
that'll
put you right into the registration
process
so again we've made this as as fast as
possible
as easy as possible we encourage you to
get tested
what i would always tell people is if
you get tested and it's negative you
also have that peace of mind
at least for that snapshot in time so we
want you to
to work with us to to do everything we
can to try to keep our community
open and to try to keep our communities
safe
as far as the process when you get here
you're going to enter off of rancho at
this location
at the texas location at
the main driveway and then you're going
to exit
uh back out over here off of lake mead
and then we also will still have our
other sites
opened up which is at
unlv and which is at cashman field
and those are still available and open
up
you can register at those at the umc
website which is umcsn.com
cashman is open tuesday through saturday
eight to four and unlv is open sunday
through thursday eight to four
and this texas location is open up
thursday through monday eight to four
so we've tried to make sure that that is
available throughout the community
we also if you check the southern nevada
health district sites
you'll see we have some strike teams
that go out for more limited testing
we've been averaging two to four of
those a week and those locations are
also available at that site
so with that i'd like to go ahead and
introduce dr lagann
and he'll speak to the the health
district and the public health
uh aspect of this thank you
thank you chief good morning
fair i i want to say that
southern nevada healthy street
our team up there they are very happy
to to be collaborating with the county
and other community partners on this
initiative of offering a testing here at
texas
station i i want to remind
our community that we are still
suffering from this pandemic that
the number of cases again
are going up in our community for the
last
four five five weeks we have been
witnessing an increase in the number of
daily cases
reported here which means that
we need to to increase our efforts
and compliance compliance
following the prevented measures that
have been recommended
to all of us and those prevented
measures
have mentioned before first is the use
of the
fascial cover or mask very important
as well as making sure that we keep the
social distancing or
fixed distance from one another
and a way as possible
spending time in public places unless
we have a valid reason to do so
i i also want to mention that
enhancing the availability of testing is
very important
to our community and to our efforts of
decreasing the spread of the virus in
crack county
and this is why this service is being
offered here
at texas station uh
together with that effort is also the
the element of contact tracing the the
healthy tree have been
increasing our manpower
uh addressing contact tracing in this
community and that's very important
because that help us
identify quickly a individual who might
have been exposed
to confirm cases of covet
in our community i i want to say that
as important as is being tested today
we also must be aware that
a negative test result today
doesn't mean that we are immune
against this disease it just means that
today we we are not infected
but potentially we could be
infected any any other day
if we are exposed to somebody with a
disease
also it is important to remember
that individuals who have been infected
recently as mostly
individuals infected less than five six
days
from the day of testing they could have
a negative result
but it's very possible that
if they start developing science
symptoms they should go
and get tested again and that is almost
likely
we come up positive
i also want to remember
everybody that even so we have
all those concerns we covered we also
are now entering into the flu season
and and that's why it's very important
for us
to to make sure that we get the flu the
flu
the flu shot because
by by getting the flu shot we are
accomplishing at least two things
first we are protecting ourselves
against the flu which every year
kills a thousand people in this country
but also we are making sure that we
that we are not suffering at any point
the possibility of being
infected by the flu and call it and then
getting into a very challenging
situation where we might develop a
severe complications whether it is from
covet
or flu so that's very important and then
in addition to that by getting the flu
shot
we are also helping the healthcare
system here in the community because
less people we need to go to the
emergency rooms or
or organ care system if we have
a lot of people here protected by the
flu vaccine
i also want to mention that we are now
entering into the the holidays
you know this is a seasonal celebration
every year where the families gather
now because of kobe we
we have to ask everybody every family to
to please uh make sure that
that we take care of ourselves and and
avoid
large congregations in our in our homes
we really emphasize the importance of
trying to limit
the number of of relatives or friends
no more than 10 people at the household
because
the more people you have at your
households
during any of those celebrations the
higher the risk
of a covey transmission amongst a
participant this is something that
that we have to be aware of against
something that
have been reported very frequently in
recent weeks
i think i should go to spanish now
right okay okay so
uh okay i'm going to go spanish now so
that's kind of difficult bueno este
el
okay
[Music]
is
okay i will stop here now and i will
call
a council government pamela goins brown
from the city of north las vegas please
good afternoon i'd first like to start
by thanking the county
the health district umc and the nevada
national guard
and all of our partners for bringing
this big testing opportunity back to the
city of north las vegas
looking at cases by city north las vegas
has the second
highest number of positives and four
of the eight zip codes are here in our
city
as the largest minority majority city in
nevada
this additional testing is extremely
crucial
to help to track how covet 19 is
spreading in our community
not only is testing important but
following the simple guidelines of
wearing a mask
maintaining social distance and washing
your hands frequently
will help out tremendously
and this is the time of year when flu
season kicks up
so please go get your flu shot do your
part to minimize
any strain on the hospital system in our
city this winter
so i just want to stress how important
it is for our residents to get tested
and just retaliate that the testing is
free
free free free at all of these locations
and
we humbly want you to take advantage of
it so thank you
oh and at this time i'd like to
introduce
julian escucha rodriguez console of
mexico
good afternoon buenas tardes
i'll start my remarks in english
nevada and las vegas as the rest of the
world have been
badly hit by copied 19.
in particular the hispanic and the
mexican community
have suffered dearly from this new virus
our communities are composed of
essential workers
that are doing
important work around the city and the
state
and we want them to be safe
and healthy so today i
join our leaders
in this community our authorities in a
special call to attention
we have to take this seriously we are
tired of
being away from our friends and family
members
we are tired of not being in parties
and social gatherings but this is the
time
to reinforce all safety and sanitary
measures
we have to wear the masks properly we
have to wear them
all the time possible we have to keep
social distancing
we have to avoid mass gatherings
or big gatherings it's important to get
tested
if you have symptoms or if you were in
contact with a person
that is sick of coronavirus
this location will be open
starting tomorrow the tests will be free
you will come in your car very safe
and you'll be able to get tested it's
important to get a flu shot
in the consulate of mexico we have
hosted several
free of cost flu vaccines
and we will continue with that and our
partners
in the community rich in particular
are conducting free of cost flu
vaccinations
in several locations around the city so
please take advantage of it
now i'll switch to spanish
mexico in las vegas
[Music]
[Music]
locales
gracias
all right well i want to thank all of
the speakers that came out today and
just
uh remind of a couple of things so one
there's been a common message here today
right social distance we're a face
covering
and wash your hands frequently go get a
flu shot
but most importantly come and get tested
so it's very quick
process i registered myself it took me
about 45
seconds and i'm not good with technology
so that says a lot
uh we asked for your name your birth
date and your phone number and that's
all the information that we ask for
i encourage families to come as a whole
there's nothing wrong with bringing your
children grandchildren
nieces or nephews to get tested and it
is a very quick process
how can you help me by doing those
common
items that i asked everybody to do as a
community
two by taking advantage of this
community testing
and three if you register the process
will go very fast
about 15 minutes and utilize
the community-wide testing we are very
fortunate in our community
because we are good at this and we can
do it
and a lot of other states are just now
getting started with this so we know how
to do it
we're going to show you today how fast
and efficient that it can be
understand that the contact tracing will
take up to about 72 hours
because we don't want it to go any
farther than that
and then lastly i just want to thank
station casinos again because it is very
hard to find a location
that gets to the community that we need
to get to
has a location that we can expedite
through so with that
we're not going to really take any
questions because everybody's going to
be around
but we're going to show you how the
testing actually works
and i'll be the person to go first so
you can
show constituents out there from start
to finish on how we get this done as a
community so thank you
and i look forward to seeing this place
very busy
thanks